So, according the commutative property, we
can rearrange everything that we had
multiplied together in this term in
whatever order we want, as long as we keep
every number we started with, or every
factor that we started with. And, we still
just multiply those number together. So,
first I'm going to check and make sure
that every answer choice has a 10, an m, a
23 and the 7 in it. And it turns out that
this answer does it, so I'll put an x next
to that. We will not be check, checking
this box off. We know that we're only
allowed to multiply these factors
together, so any answer I see that has an
operator besides a multiplication sign in
it can't be right. So here, we have some
addition. So, This answer isn't right, or
this one, or this one. Now, there are two
tricky things in here. There are
parenthesis in this answer and in this
answer. Remember, that another way to
indicate multiplication is just to write
factors next to one another, all in
parentheses. We can do this instead of
writing the dots for multiplication. So,
in fact, checking these two answers that
have the parenthesis in them, knowing now
that parenthesis mean multiplication, we
see that they are both in fact correct.
Looking at our four remaining choices, all
of these are also right answers. In fact,
there are a number of other right answers
that I just didn't chose to write down
here. Any order that we create these four
factors in as long as use to multiply them
together will still be equal to this term.